meantime some relief is on the way for
other local businesses starting on
monday
capacity levels remember they're going
to be raised now from 35 to
50 percent really depending on the
activities and the type of business
as kate houston reports while this will
give some local businesses a boost
still a long road to recovery
it's been hard but we're very fortunate
jim laughlin is the general manager of
las vegas mini grand prix
lockland says 35 percent capacity will
certainly help the indoor arcade and
seating
requirements but more needs to be done
to have an impact
we've had a few challenges on the
weekend just maintaining 25 percent
but i do think i agree with most
business owners that
the really big impact on our business
will be when we go to 50 percent
although lochlan wishes he had more
freedom when it comes to these decisions
he says the new guidelines will provide
some relief for his customers like
michael skinner and his grandkids
it's kind of nice to be able to expand
that to be able to go out and do more
things
and it's very mentally
healthy for them to do on february 15
amusement parks
gyms places of worship and bars and
restaurants such as neighbors in the
southwest
valley will operate under 35 percent
capacity
i was very happy that he gave at least
more notice than we've had in the past
starting monday reservations will not be
required at restaurants and bars and
tables will be able to hold six people
pastry chef valerie trussati says the
new guidelines will help in the short
term
but more relief efforts are needed to
keep businesses afloat
i don't think things will ever really be
back to normal i think there will
definitely be
another side of the pandemic but like i
said
long term in hospitality industry in
itself
it's going to take a long time to
recover kate houston
8 news now so on monday retail stores
and indoor malls as well as libraries
and rec centers they're going to move to
50
capacity for an in-depth breakdown of
these new capacity guidelines there's a
lot of to look at
we put it for you on our website at
8newsnow.com